so it's a free country these were made
cat made these rinks
these are Crocs
so I'm gonna fight and this is what a
man decides who he is and what it's
worth
Brenda system with an anthem so guess
what
Oh
I know you want Crocs that bad good 8126
Wilshire Boulevard healing Machado
judges he teach you pull your nuts and
Bulldog them all the spare in love and
war brother you know black tux is a
company I've used when I went to
Joseph's wedding and oh yeah you wore a
tux like Doug's got myself nice and
measured and fit like a glove cuz they
took my measurements they stay had it to
me in time well I mean up and turn it if
there were any problems there were no
problems is what I like about a dude
black tuxes they have easy online
ordering process it brings you the suit
or tuxedo straight to you just pick a
style - black tux calm and request a
free home try on so you can feel the fit
and quality before you really commit to
this thing right the fine lines not your
style the black tux has showrooms all
over the country so you can go on in and
when you when you get fitted for a tux
it's so much different
dude just ship you your order two weeks
before your wedding so you and check it
out one last time talk about commitment
with your buying your outfit or look
into rent you won't find a formal world
experience designs like the ones you'll
find that the blacktop
I'll give you a similar deal Brian give
us a long story as rinks let me give you
a story I'm in my black tux I'm in
Boston and a woman staring at me I'm at
this height the hotel that we stayed in
Boston she looks at me and she just goes
she's with her guy and I look at her and
I figure she recognized me she goes it
just looks good
tux it just looks good on you I don't
believe this where'd a guy like well
thank you very much
never help that it did happen actually
that did happen black tux
uh black tux calm tu X spelled the black
tux calm enjoy ten percent off with koti
phat K that's the black tux calm koti
fat K for ten percent off your purchase
the black tux formal wear for the moment
athletic greens if you don't want to eat
from twenty five servings of fruits and
vegetables you can get it in essentially
you can get 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients with
athletic greens through just a little
powder just a little bit water I love it
every morning every morning nice
capsules yep all heaven meal
yep 75 vitamins dude 75 they got
prebiotics probiotics digestive enzymes
adaptogens superfoods and more and
basically helps your body with
nutritional needs and everything else so
all you have to do is your your whether
you're taking a step toward a healthier
life or an athlete pushing for better
performance athletic greens gives you
the nutrients and the greens and
everything else you need to thrive go to
athletic greens comm slash fighter and
claim me offer a free tub of 20 servings
all-natural New Zealand 20 well New
Zealand sourced 100% grass oh get way
program ray that's micros and macros you
got you covered
athletic greens calm slash fighter for
the special offer wow you got a nice
nice tight high ass till I got a nice
hand I didn't expect you know me I get
brainwashed [ __ ] here's one the best ass
I've seen in the game it's plumping its
high and it's tight and you bolts look
like what I thought your balls would
look like yeah
do it that legit took everything in my
power because I didn't know that was
gonna happen for me to not take a lick
yeah that's what happened home in your
mouth cuz when he makes him when he puts
him out like that cuz I thought that my
baby all right but it's not cured the
baby brain tell you story when I was
young man I was probably 18 years old in
Russia in communist Russia i hook up
with this gal i meet these two girls in
the lobby turned out there were probably
hookers now girls I need help with their
rent now listen my buddy he couldn't do
it with Christina it was Christina and
Svetlana and he couldn't he couldn't
pull the trigger or and get his yeah he
was you know you've never been around
another guy I me I don't give a [ __ ]
I'll have second need any with my boys
we've been honest that's it hey yeah but
you know what I mean it's ah no no I
know but just take it easy
apologize and and the point is I'm there
and he can't perform so I go whoa come
join he's a practice player that's right
so I'm giving it to Svetlana giving it
to her at 17 18 years old condom or no
condom of course no condom now yeah come
on is Russia
that's Russia its Russian I have a
recipe this is 1989 oh yeah maybe no 85
maybe I can't afford you were good so my
mother caught me that's a whole nother
story doesn't matter now
now she comes over now as I'm going to
town on on fat Lana and then I go to
town because did not come back to speed
Lana Harvey curvy in the eighties oh the
best the best the best the best the best
Christina a bit my boy holy cheese no
just the cheek it was so shocking to me
Oh like that Wow yeah and did you would
you would you drop your American load
yeah you know believe it or not I don't
remember I literally don't remember but
it wasn't anything poor neglecting those
stars and stripes yeah it was probably
it was probably you know I'm gonna say
this another gay man but I've seen my
share fair digs
so I'm Chris's dick today send him a pic
of us and it is it's a long and little
thin you know this want this
I got cursed long thin long and thin and
and and you can verify one more which is
not that bad
it's one more no just like that is bad
right that's it's just one there's guys
are there in double digits I have one
we're a little wart now we gotta get
that taken care of I asked him how much
he bandaged he lied to me I didn't lie
to you and I got [ __ ] also I got good
news too just just hot off the president
doctor are you cool if I choke on your
your yeah absolutely oh absolutely
um just so everybody just win a barstool
sports shirt by the way in the it's not
a bad dick dude
no no good I was impressed for not this
kid's got a [ __ ] piece on him I got a
hug I'm very impressed with that it's
long it's got some girl long yeah a
little bit
yours is girth you for sure I'm gonna
we're in the middle of you two yeah no
my big looks at your dicks head babies
the stefanos got a piece on dude I told
you I'm solid eight inches on touches
nine butt warts nine with warts yeah
that's a that's a Brooklyn no dude come
on
yeah so brooklyn oh ye like I got this
just just had to tea
well the last I read the comic store
meet him in Santee and I get the picture
from Troy I said I hit your hey we
models yeah home to friendly models 9:00
a.m. you goon so it I was driving oh my
god yeah dude
well good for you man and then I just
got the email today chlamydia track of
my tightest negative gonorrhea and
gonorrhea RNA negative vaginitis
positive no it's the herpes one negative
herpes 2 positive negative HIV mm-hmm we
don't know negative negative negative so
far negative yeah but it's good the
other thing I have is a tad bit high
cholesterol but I have been plant-based
90% plant base which is on it's been
interesting because the last time I came
on here you know I fully I wanted to be
in a relationship with Brian and I'm not
saying I don't want to do that but I do
feel like since I've added mostly
planted to my diet the gay feels
somewhat cured right um but I still do
like it's one of those things where like
now I'll just I'll have a gay thought
sure and I'll eat zucchini hey guy then
you're good now then I just feel like
until Kelly got his nuts out and I saw
your mouth water that's what happened
then I was then I stood because I want
plants but then I was like give me sweet
potato I want to put it in my ass yeah
so was it I just didn't want to eat at
the regular way let me ask you was just
yeah you are plant-based what was your
cholesterol give me a number my
cholesterol was when I started plant bay
before I started doing this was 250
total cholesterol that's like Italian
fat dick that's high you know and now
high I don't know climb was 150 40 was I
got a little hot I just don't get that
pressure yeah plant is very fat Cugini
and now now now you have to look at
oxidized cholesterol sighs the market
with all kinds of [ __ ] things I bet
do fifty usually put you on statin
totally and the doctor was like listen
you're 35 years old what are you doing
and he asked me honestly he was like
tell me what you eat and I said he said
what food to eat the most and I'm being
honest I was like let me think he said
yeah it's important that I know and then
I said probably pizza and he said okay
it's New York City how many slices of
pizza do you eat a week and this is a
real number okay he was like think about
it's his seven days this is a seven-day
cycle I told him and I was confident
with this number that I eat 28 slices of
pizza week okay all right did you do
when you took your cholesterol did you
had you eaten before did you fast no I
did the fasting cholesterol everything
you know I didn't eat for eight eight to
ten the 250 is of total read what was
your LDL my LDLs I believe were my LDLs
were like 150 they were high my high
cholesterol my hike my good cholesterol
time my HDLs were high which is positive
yeah so that's why he wasn't too
concerned but the LDLs and the
triglycerides were TTR through the roof
and do you think that scientist on New
York Pizza
it was the pizza it was it was all the
fat and meat that I believe I was eating
triglycerides not good you don't want
that high that was high but then but
then baby girl did the did the
plant-based diet 90% I can't go ever I
still eat meat 97 plant-based and the
total cholesterol is 190 move everything
here I have it everything
have you been doing it I was doing it
for about six to eight weeks but because
Chris Johnny boy over here is doing me I
can just read me because I haven't had
anything but read mundane but poopy beer
you don't have any cholesterol issues
right have you had last time you had
checked 1984 nah I got blood checked in
general if Bubba's does if you don't
have any monkey but if you don't have
any cholesterol issues then you can eat
the meat I had daddy had cholesterol I
was I see three large pies a week and a
lot of sweets I was eating a lot is
sweet to your eyes my trinket slides
were through the [ __ ] roof but you
you don't have like a skinny fat build
on you I know you always talk about your
tits
I do have fat off-center nipples my
total cholesterol now as of February 5th
was 191 total cholesterol HDL is at 61
triglycerides at 75 non-hd ELLs at 101
to speak in Ethiopian LDL cholesterol
116 and the V LDL cholesterol which is
for transgender people was 15 you got a
transgender B yeah okay so I had a
transgender identify as a transgender
man I tell you first trans I well right
now I think it depends because here's
the thing is if if if you know we live
in a free society right now and there's
days where I do genuinely feel like a
transgender Eskimo so I don't know why I
can't just get in my little igloo so
it's the end of a piece of halibut and
make it a [ __ ] its Inuit it's not a
date me and you baby I used to date
there's something about that mustache I
feel like I've been tickled by you
before that's not even a mustache that's
a mustache oh this was last yeah we call
it a mustache would you do what do you
do now in LA again dude why are you out
here in Los Angeles
yes I was doing I did I'm your guys
podcast do Thea Vaughn's podcast and
then tomorrow I'm doing stand-up on the
Jimmy Kimmel show oh but he does it in
Vegas so I wanted to come out from his
comedy club from his comedy club in Las
Vegas
yes but they produce and shoot for it's
not live right they just put add it into
the TV show yeah there's a few people
that are gonna do it and then he just
will put it out whenever I I'm looking
forward to do it but I only said you
have to do it because I was like oh this
gives me a reason to come to LA and get
on the podcast
I like Kimmel yeah I like him I just I
don't know him but he I just everybody I
know I know his sister do you see him
doing right Kobe Bryant stuff I guess
the host mr. monster monster he show is
the edgiest coolest one out of all those
late nights you ever see him crying over
Don Rickles oh yeah no I love that
you're seeing cry I mean he's crying he
was crying on overtime he loved Don
Rickles me I couldn't stop crying it was
just [ __ ] gay homo for them no no in
this climate I'm sorry to plants my VLDL
are high man playing that on your on
your bigotry do it I'm kidding
how'd you know it was bigotry and racism
is um bigotry and racism bigotry and
racism no I don't you're a bigot versus
being a racist yeah I guess big it means
you're essentially prejudiced against it
could be anything it could be individual
if you're racist you're you're
prejudiced against race but if you're
bigoted you're really gonna race I see
but you'll be bigoted but you could be
racist towards multiple hmm races you're
just saying it's just racist without
words a bigot he's a bigot you you can
be but you can I think racism and
tribalism is just a part of us as human
beings yes and it's it's like doesn't
make you all bad you know what I mean
like my dad when Staten Island there was
a hurricane on hurricane sandy in 2012
and my dad lived on Staten Island and
the coast of Stalin was ravaged right
but my father lived a little bit inland
so he would get a u-haul truck every
single day and go down and help the
families mostly Latino families help
them out take their kids to school
everything but simultaneously while he
was doing that just because he's
old-school guy from the Bronx like the
leader of the fam one family took in the
patriarch his name was Jose my dad just
called him one you know or like it's
just he was like hey kids don't steal my
silverware like old hack jokes you know
he was like where's your [ __ ]
passports if you got alcohol I'll get
ice in here in a second
are you citizens but he was taking them
to school every day washing their
clothes everything like that you know
guys old school mentality like but it's
like in 2020 somebody who's [ __ ]
woken dope would be like about my dad's
a pig and it's like yeah he was doing
more than you were yeah with your dumb
with his hand paper strong he's a good
pig he's a good pick my dad's a good
good good I always say that it's your
intention
what if you're doing something to make
the world a better place with you
physically then you have a higher
standing absolutely that's why I feel
like I literally genuinely everyo
anytime anytime I go I'm sorry oh my god
sorry they're so distracting do I don't
know please don't get your good luck
I'll [ __ ] [ __ ] plants can feel like
I'm in 90% plant pace I'm gonna be
honest with you right now
because last time I was about being a
relationship but I'm just [ __ ] horny
because I haven't had me so if you pull
your dick out they're gonna get sucked
all right well here you go they're cute
well you got pretty happy deaf just MPI
dextrous nose yeah I do
dexterity if your feeder does even a
corgi on your this is cat these are
amazed I'm why they drive vaginas up
everywhere but I'm gonna wear these cats
that if I set them on fire
I love no by all means I actually hate
Crocs ooh but they're cute shame these
got to be like a hung up good real nice
awesome what did they say on them well
it says ranks this is wrinkly old Rick I
thought his ass was I thought his skin
was no I give him that he has a JLo ass
I got a fat you said I'm built like a
frog yep because when I did my genome I
was so excited it's mostly fast twitch
muscle yeah go for speed and power and I
was like Brandon he goes yeah you're
built like a frog Kermit the Frog yeah
so like what I was saying before it's
like is like you know like I'm someone
and this is just where I come from where
it's like I feel like I donate to go
fund me any time I see a homeless person
I not only offer the money I offer them
food and water so why am I not allowed
to then yell racial slurs at non-whites
and Kristen Chris
because you [ __ ] can't I don't
understand the only words you can't do
nice things for people just so you can
be in a vocal racist but I'm giving
homeless people [ __ ] full bagels
close to my butter I know dude you can't
burn a [ __ ] point he's clearly doing
this so he can exercise his right to be
a complete son of a [ __ ] realized yeah
I can't I can't throw a mask at an Asian
person say put this on you coronavirus
[ __ ] I gave a guy if I gave literally
gave a homeless guy a dollar yeah if I
gave a homeless guy a forbidden racist
you're buying a ring on this guy dollar
I can't go on the subway and say hey
before that we surprised I was not so
surprised the question is does Biden or
Bernie pull out the ultimate nomination
I say but I think it's gonna be Joe
Biden as far as you think Biden's gonna
be the reals like actually the Democrat
I was surprised most most people like I
didn't think that many people like Biden
I find him like very your face he's been
around yeah he's kind of like a Scranton
Pennsylvania canonize he's a easy easy
East kind of people as loosey-goosey and
liberal as Bernie was thinking on the
route when it comes down to everyone's I
think Trump b-boys gonna win again
though well complete our journey we with
the thing is like you like Brian said
before it's like this is this what we
gotta pick from well they sing something
like any of them the best thing somebody
said about Bernie Sanders one of the
things that you but it's good about
Bernie is that he speaks his mind
yeah he's as authentic as he can as he
guys but but one things if somebody says
when Bernie Sanders talks about free
College free healthcare he's he is a guy
who believes those things should be
moral rights right that's an argument
Wow and I respected but but at the end
of the day when it comes to actually
paying for it when it comes down to the
nitty-gritty at all that's where he'll
find is that okay to say no Brooklyn Jew
right yeah Brooklyn gym but he lives in
Vermont
he's a Brooklyn Jew who's actually I
think almost anti-israel he's got these
he's got these very sort of unpopular
Jewish views he's he's a guy who took
his honeymoon in the Soviet Union and he
did yes he went to this dude let me know
next time all up in my mouth oh no
that's the other thing people are around
my set on the show people are L bumping
elbows my hands right now I love that
people by the corona man by the masks
like those masses nothing that's not
going to do anything and it only helps
if you have if you have the virus it
keeps it so you don't get other people's
that's it basically let me tell you
something right now that that [ __ ]
faut basically that that kabhi you said
to come so kiss me tell my friend this
meter know in front of all my friends
I'm like what's up duty it's come in
here I'm like what yeah okay what are
you gonna do do I think you and I could
get on the Octagon and you'll stick to
the floor because I'll come all over you
you're not gonna [ __ ] my spider webs on
you and pin you one tooth today
chlamydia free guy I got the results
it's true listen the corona virus I
don't think for a second effects of
eating bats I think if that was
biochemically made in a lab in China and
they make it and then the people that
wear the masks are so [ __ ] stupid
because the masks are made in China
they're dipping the mask in the corona
virus sent them to the United States
it's a whole conspiracy that I know that
the liberal [ __ ] [ __ ] have made to
try to crash the economy and you're not
gonna take down Trump Trump 2020
I'm just what you get it around here's
your month I play itself across the line
I do
sorry is it live can we add a highway we
can light we can any guys could keep it
but I just feel like that I thought I
was having fun with the thing and that I
said kick that and then I saw people put
their heads down when I say here's your
month right I love it support all black
people and people of any race culture
and Creed and transgender people I love
it literally there's not a peep there's
not a group of people on this [ __ ]
planet that I don't love except the
Vietnamese because we're at war [ __ ]
sandwiches and I love you I can't I'm
kidding around I was just joking you
weren't battle Eskimos you were me silly
boots me maybe one release just a few
shoot Kim Oh silly silly goose I'm just
I'm because I was just saying I don't
I'm kiddin I love everybody have a
Puerto Rican child that's true you do
get a little again you get away with a
lot did because your your your your
baby's Mama's Puerto Ricans Porto Rican
and all I saw baby mama last night what
a nice tits right well really she's hot
she's bein here like the same type we're
the same type
yeah hot curvy and Latin yeah yeah mmm
me too well yeah she's spicy my kid and
I want to get back with her I think -
I'd like to get back on my kids mom I'm
just done to make it work I'm just done
are you tired I'm tired and I'm like why
am i missing so many I see my daughter
every single day but it's still like
there's times I just go back it's 10
o'clock at night you know put her to bed
and then I go back to my apartment I'm
like whoa what the [ __ ] why am i she
still should are you not waking up with
her well I I wake up with her Tuesdays
and Thursdays and every other weekend
but there's still other days I'm like I
don't know I don't want to I just miss I
think I missed the family make bite the
bullet and jump back in jump right back
in this is baby mama down though
baby mama G why did you guys end up in
the first place um because we got into
an argument and I didn't give her my
phone and she kicked the air-conditioner
out the window let's fish that's she's
Dominican what if she's Puerto Rican
tougher so we just no you know what it
is we we had she conceived the baby on
like our second or third
so we didn't know each other at all and
then we tried to make this thing work
and it didn't work but now I'm like you
know what like two years under yeah we
broke up for two years you had a
boyfriend I had my life
what are we just trying to make this
thing working me down I think she would
she's hot she's hot she's hot she kiss
and what you are right you want babe
skills give a run [ __ ] Brandon dude I
know it's the mother of my kid and but
I'm being dead sure she's hot yes so
[ __ ] beautiful and her dick who is
your Afghani friend who's sitting next
year this is died who's the alley cat
version your boy huh I was gonna say
this we call him handsome Yanis yeah
this is done this is Don de peda
um Don do you have a mic no 100% of time
percent of time no he's a hundred what
are you showing us baby mama right show
baby mama but Walt don't introduce
yourself so you're gonna show him the
tit that a good one load up the Gila
nice daddy last night daddy a few of
them yeah you did yes would you like
what she sees a very thick one I like to
think one yet some real New York yeah
subway Ali or Rican which I like it's
just a great lace has some New York hoes
in that phone now yeah yeah you know you
could you could peruse you're gonna see
Jeb you can show much one you saw Beauty
face you and she looks just like my
daughter she looks like [ __ ] a young
she looks like heaven she looks like a
young you know who isn't the wrestler
she's hotter than mr. Tomac her
stomach's beautiful her body's way
better mr. plays great you know a good
time good time
she's so I'm thinking like now it's time
why not because you know what it wasn't
separates they don't congrats I was
finding trying to always find ways to
get out of the relationship when when we
when you know comics yourself soundTouch
oh yeah because I like self-sabotage me
was like I don't really know her
everyone's like you should have the baby
but like you don't really know her so I
was always like this is a red flag
that's what it's like but then next time
when I'm like yeah she was scared
because and I was scared we had a baby
we didn't even know each other like it's
not going to be that's not going to be
an easy relationship
and I feel like never for seven years a
baby's gonna be ya know but she does
want she has expressed interest you know
in another day well because we both have
been like why don't why I mean why we
[ __ ] got the kids I pay for your
place I pay for my place like with like
why don't we just be attracted to her
hell yeah we're still trying
great mom she's a excellent my hold your
baby my baby's gonna be five in two
months
great I'm there in May let me be the
middleman I'll be your doctor foo
absolutely nom be the doctor Phil I know
but basically feel as though you're you
don't have pure intentions what's going
on we'll see well here's your month look
you don't want to keep don't bring
hungry eyes around your girl I know
because he gets girls oh no I know it
does but the problem is the big man the
big man I don't know girls kind of they
want it they get all weird around the
big man I know I know she loved him they
all loves him and loves him they all
love it but that's okay the only other
issue we I have is pajamas
I'm wearing a little pajama pants oli
where's the thing is the thing is that
was my kids mom is that you you know I I
she would like you I think she would
like you a lot but she i'm confident
even with your professional fighting
experience you just i don't know she's
got that internal gear that internal
thinking of your that that she'll
[ __ ] she'll get she'll say have you
in the pancreas yeah yeah you'll bleed
your pancreas out she doesn't know i
mean she has an eighth grade education
but you'll find your pancreas and put
put it's not sewn on it yeah she the
next thing you know your pancreas in
empanada and she's eaten in front of you
i know my girls from guadalajara and
it's a [ __ ] nightmare they have a
good cartel there yeah though some say
the best some say the best yeah not not
not big on the human rights so yeah but
you know not everyone it's not our
mexico what you're hanging from a bridge
well i mean this book on mexico you know
five percent of all murders get solved
and make though five percent I just want
to murder somebody you're doing a mess
where where was what book is it it's
this L job catching El Chapo oh wow
right fantastic five thousand five
percent of all murders get solved that
seems high that's what I think that's
how's that Philly it's wonderful asked
how take cuz they don't care cuz they're
like and so corrupt they're not looking
into it every drink ajar Ito
[ __ ] nicely I don't know it's just a
bear I thought it's Mexican it's some
nice little drink that I like to drink
just a nice little
Teredo a generate oh yeah jaw teeth all
put on a baseball game watch those
[ __ ] guys went around the bases oh
the little the little eat the fruit
punch to get those CC Guan yes yeah do
it
yes oh I love all groups man truly I do
well because you're what I was gonna say
it's like being born and raised in New
York City it's like you can't really be
racist or hate any group because whoever
you think you hate you're gonna see them
on the train in five minutes yeah so
it's like it's really tough to be like a
true racist correct in New York it's
really I joke around to really be
quieted I gotta be committed like
literally like Howard Beach which is
like old-school like mafia [ __ ] like
even those guys you know would be like
listen you know what nobody's [ __ ]
saying any slurs over here but they'll
rob you and kill your grandmother but
they won't you know I mean racism yeah
it's not a thing I feel like when it
gets more isolated in certain parts of
our country it's like you know Dawn's
from Atlanta I mean they're dropping a
[ __ ] are on the n-word it's something
his dad owns there the punch line in
Atlanta did you know I didn't know that
yeah I've never been a punch line
Atlanta
I hope do you want to come tonight
Johnny I think you've outgrown it I'm
the Ottoman army Atlanta next week yeah
you're at the TAT what do you got
theater it's good right it's really not
good dude last night was fun at the
story hell yeah was - to watch my set I
watched you set the the crowd was a
little strange they were strange and I
was gonna listen but Santino then
started talking I'm shaking now and all
that yeah and and I thought I thought
that it was a good I thought that it was
I was because we were - Brent and I were
talking before and I was like you got
respect from your peers and the crowd
loves you so those two things are the
hardest things because as far as bombing
goes trying the material I mean you're
just gonna eat a fat one once - you
didn't need a fat one but I'm saying you
have to see the dick that I [ __ ] ate
two weeks ago at the Comedy Cellar it's
one of those things where I mean I'm
funny I'm getting a full set ho a zero
bombing because I was doing new jokes
about I was I did my answer she calm and
I was doing jokes about being German and
then that just went too far as Germans
do yes so they it was bombing we were
you goose-stepping and Heil Hitler
I was yeah I was blitzed now it was at
50 minutes that was a 15 minutes of a
full
oh yeah it's a very tight room your
peers watching though because I want to
do really good cuz I knew you and
Santino in the corner and Illya why
don't I go watch well I guess you could
see it consider this man appear I
thought nobody was watching it was
literally one of those bombs so I was
sweating I could feel the sweat dripping
down my spine I was nauseous I literally
was nauseous coming off I turned the
corner go up the stairs Chris Rock who's
that Oh then I was like hi Chris like hi
and he was just like just looked at me I
just went on and annihilated yeah but I
mean a full body but I tried new stuff
and I don't Chris no one post that
they'd be so good I think people to see
that you don't know when you're gonna
eat all the day but if you could somehow
capture that and post that because we
all post the best moments right that's
roller coaster special or sold-out
crowds but if you could post you eating
[ __ ] well because there's nothing funny
or too exciting than watching a good
comedian really Bob just watching the
hardest I ever made my friends left I
went to the Friars Club here in LA and I
looked at them and I was young probably
[ __ ] this was when I was 34 years old
and I said I go I'm doing 45 minutes
only on birds I did this thing about
having a giant eagle and the things I
would do the ego dude I'm talking about
you could hear Clank thing all you can
hear is people eating just shoes like
you could hear the clink of their of
their [ __ ] as they were eating dinner
yeah and but my friends who are comics
in the back like just dying I was eating
I was I and that was and Steve Byrne
misty were there he was laughing sore
because I just kept going right I just
got double I would gobble down I go I'm
one of the top bird humerus in the
country I'm sorry av and satirist and I
don't keep doing dude I just kept doing
it burned I did it again me and Steve
had to do a stand-up at Columbia College
well in front of wait for it a bunch of
Asian graduate students in math why
would they you guys influenced
oh no dude it was back when I just first
started doing the road and it was a
[ __ ] college thing God knows how much
nothing and I got up and I and again I
was like well these people aren't gonna
get any Steve eight dicks I ate the
biggest dick you guys are in the mad
watch this
what's the deal with Eagles even the
master God I was doing all kinds of
weird [ __ ] you ever [ __ ] wrangle a cow
blah blah blah do colleges yeah I do
college oh really
well I yeah I do them now a little bit
but I wasn't I would couple years he's
not allowed to anymore no dude the
podcast my historian is podcasts cuz we
just go [ __ ] wild for history nature
they um the colleges are starting to
come around again cuz their kids listen
to it and it's like you know we're just
talking about uncomfortable truths in
history but the best thing to do is when
you're bombing like in New York in the
Comedy Cellar name just eating a zero
like you know those old school guys
Bobby Kelly Keith Robertson Colin Quinn
you'll just like bomb and then you're
just like so where you're from and
bought you'll hit Bobby go shut up
you're bombing shut up and they'll just
be like heckling you from the back and
you're just eating it even more you'll
owe everyone Bobby Kelly they're like
shut up you're eating it shut up
sitting the bomb the bomb you're trying
to get out of it in the bomb you're as
good as your last joke I was a fan
dude one minute ago I made I made the a
big big big mistake once to have like I
did comedy on the Seth Meyers show and I
thought that was a big deal in 2015 and
I had like a viewing party for it at the
Comedy Cellar and all those guys showed
up and that Jim Norton just annoying
like annihilating me just about the
cenotes that I was doing and Colin Quinn
being like really Bobby Kelly like
really dude this is what we're [ __ ]
here for a five minute Seth Meyers
set
how great is Bobby Kelly number one now
I mean just the way that you get trashed
the thing is with the Comedy Cellar is
when you sit at that back table
especially like the way that where it's
cornered there if you're sitting there
and like SD the Booker's there in the
old-school guys there and you're like
and they start making fun of you you
can't physically get out of it so either
you have combat so because if they smell
blood like if Keith Robinson starts to
really pick up you're just gonna get
annihilated and it's gonna hurt bad like
you're just as I scare me I mean I've
been missing a visceral Norden baby ugly
like you can't do anything
Norton's vile oh yeah he's just start to
take a hot one what happens but that's
it's it's so the old-school New York
[ __ ]
I know people didn't remember Rogan when
he was younger but Rogan when I first
met Rogan the he was a he was a [ __ ]
Boston comic oh yeah and dude when he
would he was a guy he was like a killer
he used to he destroy rooms like I'd be
like what the [ __ ] and I was kind of
like always trying to act but I would
dabble around with stand upright and
that guy would be like I'd be like aw
that guy's funny he goes he's [ __ ]
the wife yes follow me one time [ __ ]
like he literally was like a sport for
him it's Jay Mohr from Boston - or
Taymor as a monster we saw him less I'm
seeing Fred wood as good a comic in many
ways there is I've ever exactly the day
you talking about straight Jay Jay more
in a lot of ways is is so Talent he was
so taser acting his [ __ ] standard
German wire he was great Jerry Maguire
nice he's he's a beast he's not
overdoing him on the road
J Martin started I used to prefer Jay
Mohr and Artie Lange those are the two
Jesus yeah because how I hung dozes this
was in 2011 funniest - Guardian game or
who I both of whom I know very well why
are moms my way I started opening for
Artie was I was at Caroline's Caroline's
in 2011 Lewis fir anda used to just book
me to like open for everyone so I was
opening for Richard Lewis and Richard
Lewis he's notorious for this he will
not sit in the green room in between
shows he just will not sit anywhere he
go outside and goes back to his hotel
that's what he does he doesn't
and he just shows up for first 18 times
that's what he does what he doesn't want
to talk to her
smells won't do anything he has sold out
400 T is it every night sold out I
literally have 10 minutes of material at
most 12 minutes stretching the [ __ ] out
of my head I'm been doing comedy for 18
months but they're having the empty
weekend shows because Lewis is like see
something whatever so I've been doing
it's fine Thursday night shows fine it
was the same thing they give me the
light at nine minutes that means
Richards there bring up Richard do your
last joke Richard Lewis fine fine fine
Friday nights and I chose great Saturday
8:00 o'clock fine
everything good now this is my fifth
show Saturday ten o'clock goes and I
[ __ ] like clockwork nine minutes I
know I'm gonna do my [ __ ] you know
whatever newbie vent your clothes or
blah blah blah who cares bring up
Richard Lewis nine minutes I get there
no light ooh
so I'm like what's going on and then a
couple of minutes go by I'm stretching
it out whatever I see Lewis in the back
going like this with his hand being like
keep going keep going
what dude I had ten minutes twelve if I
[ __ ] stretched it 58 minutes let me
tell you Richard I Richard Lewis in the
car service back to his hotel had gotten
into a car accident had hittin a drunk
driver he was fine had hit rich Lewis
the police wouldn't let him leave until
everything was assessed so he had
nowhere to he couldn't leave 58 minutes
dude I asked every single person in the
crowd where they were from the only
thing that I know every by know every
state capital I was having people yell
at a state I would yell the capital I
was just people I thought there's only
50 states ran out of that then I had a
guy then I had a guy come up and tried
two minutes to stand up he [ __ ] blew
me out of the water just so I got him
off then I had I was asking people what
they had for lunch I mean literally I
was like you don't understand to me I
had this 12 minutes I get 58 [ __ ]
minutes is it worse than I'm worth like
being at school and listening I swear to
God I bring up Richard Lewis I'm like Oh
finally I see light I'm like thank God I
see him does it say anything goes guys
give it up for David my own
I thought my name is David the whole tie
my shoe JIT literally I mean people get
paid edger no not a [ __ ] cent not a
cent I still have to pay 850 I still
have to pay for my [ __ ] cheeseburger
have for Jesus Christ yeah any road
strays jay moriarty well job well that's
why I brought that Richard Lewis thing
up yes already Lange saw that our new
language one of the guys in the back and
I come on cuz Artie's a Comics comic I
come off and Artie's like dude he goes I
do exactly what was happening he said I
was telling Lois I'll go up there I'll
say her husband Greg Lewis was like no
he's got to learn he's got a long and
I'm but but 58 minutes right like you I
was almost gonna [ __ ] kill myself I
was gonna [ __ ] start mill slitting my
wrists with the butter not just
entertain you don't have the material
let's stand I can't do anything so Artie
Lange sees that and then the way it
worked out what's our he's like listen
man I'm gonna bring you on the road he
drove me all the way back home to my
house he's the nicest human being all
guy great Artie Lange was great he's the
best person in the world and this is
already was you know sober then and he
was saying any sober now by the way I'm
happy to see Artie's like sober and
already uh but at that point he was
sober and um he was like listen man I
just want a guy you know like you young
young guy seems hungry nice guy good
family he's like I just want you to like
you be with me in between shows like we
get out of the green room we walk around
we just stay away from the booze stay
away from the girls like you don't have
any habits and I said I don't and he was
like and he was like yes you come with
me and then we would go on the road and
this is already you know 2011 it's just
like late 2011 he you know is Howard
Stern fans were [ __ ] vicious too like
I remember do dis meaning like felt like
they just want Artie and there's little
work I performed
that's what I used to open I opened for
him a couple of times yeah they were all
Howard Stern fans the height of his
powers yeah
they were so [ __ ] drunk rowdy it was
out of control no literally Count Basie
Theatre whatever that holds 12 1500
[ __ ] sold out I'm being serious
literally this is maybe the second
shoppin for already
all right he was like hey you know it's
count baby it's Jersey like these
they're animals out there you know do
five minutes bring me up a potato be
fine I'm not lying you dude I I had on
up I had on this purple eye on this
purple button down shirt I don't know
why I have I come out there like please
welcome stage Chris Stefano you know
half the people clap whatever from the
[ __ ] last row in the upper deck as
soon as I take the mic out of the stand
perfect somebody goes nice shirt [ __ ]
explodes and laughter already has to
come they save you Artie comes on the
god mic from the back goes give the kid
a chance give him a chance he goes
t-shirts socks I'll give it to him let
me do like three jokes they let me do
like three jokes and then a woman from
the front was like honey hunt like I
could hear her she didn't even nobody
heard she was like honey bring up Artie
on stage big [ __ ] guys drunk
literally at the funny people in st.
Louis coast he gets up and he goes those
are gay [ __ ] boots and that's how it
started
yeah they [ __ ] yeah by the way I don't
condone the f-word I just wanted to just
want to say that's what that guy said
maybe that's a motif philadelphia forum
modi comes out hope and and the guy goes
and he was like he was like [ __ ] do more
how long do you towards art I toured
with Artie for the whole summer of 2011
2012 and then already told me he was
like hey man I think you know not that I
was a headliner yet he's like but he's
like you've opened for me like I feel
like I gave you the experience I go try
to work on featuring for other people
get in the improv get on the funny bones
like Artie is one of those comics that
will never ever ever he's like is so
comfortable who he is he just wants to
see the younger comedians do well he'll
do anything he can to help he's just
like a great guy that's why like when he
was having his like substance struggles
like anybody would try to help him
because he was like yeah we don't want
to lose Artie yeah me know like because
he's just such a great guy but now he's
like totally how things on stage just
[ __ ] destroying
again III I've always said this there
are two people who I think of the
funniest people I've ever been around
on on like a personal when you're just
hanging out of them like geniuses
genius-level Artie Lange and Zach
Galifianakis
ya know those two those two are to me in
all my years of doing comedy as far as
like just like could be like being
around like raw athletes those athletes
where you just go like Alden Smith and
those guys you like that's the best
absolutely I've seen or met you know
he's a freak a slate is what I'm saying
like physically yeah but but like yeah
but you told me you say the best athlete
ever met right I mean he's 65 to 60 and
no Alden Smith yes okay whatever yeah
the point is it's bad the point is it's
a night like like as far as just raw raw
genius and ability to be funny like and
improvise and do sit where you just go
oh my you're so [ __ ] so that so then
did you go from RT 2 J Moore J Moore
with a shame work around it
J Moore was kind of around that same
time i I to 911 2011-2012 is one J & J
we would open I would open J was great
but every with J it's like when you're
in the green with J it's like he's
always putting you in like wrestling
moves
he's [ __ ] teabag and you enjoy
wrestling me last night yeah I've seen
him in like dry wrestle me too so I
literally would like literally sometimes
I would come limping out onto stage cuz
J like tweaked my back just puttin me in
some [ __ ] move and I was like in pain
so we so I was like hey man like he
would ask me for certain dates was like
I just don't wanna get beat up today so
I'm just not I'm gonna pass and then he
you know wound up falling out but I
haven't seen J in years before I saw him
yes I feel he hasn't been doing stand-up
I think he's been doing heroin I think
he went to a divorce when it was tough
on him tough on and then you know
wrestling coach at Palisades I yeah he's
the head wrestling coach
palisades I Jerry was a high school
wrestler yeah it was great to see J
again head wrestling coach yeah that's
amazing so he's just not that into
acting and stuff like that anymore I
don't know you'd have to talk to
people's come on the podcast [ __ ]
last night you got man come on come on
yeah I love that I just said heroin and
people like yikes
I was kidding but it seems like people
know more than I do
close kid is full joke sorry J so sorry
so then you went so you went already
monster J more monster and then what and
then and then already Monster J more
monster and then what happened after
that then I got on the shows guy code
and girl code which became popular shows
among college kids MTV and that was
Schultz also on their shoulders on that
schultzy Charlamagne Lil Duval myself
Nicole Byers jessimae Peluso Jesus
correctly know a lot of Italians and a
lot of talent yeah yeah yeah and then
and then so we did that show and that
became really popular and then and then
I started you know I started headlining
on my own or about 2008 2014 um and I
just started you know and then that
literally it's it's been crazy because
from 2000 I was telling Donny this the
other day from 2014 to 2019 out of all
those years of headlining five years of
headlining I got one I made one bonus in
Boston but it was because it was around
Christmas green sell selling out so yeah
hit a certain percentage yeah until you
had the bonus to make yeah I made one
bonus and then from 2019 to now it's
like 90% of them are bonuses so it's
been I feel like I you know headline and
like I've been grinding it for like ten
years which I know a lot of people have
been grinding it way longer but also a
lot of people way shorter so I just feel
like you know now it's like I have part
doing these podcasts and putting my
stuff on the internet I feel like I'm I
can give people a not all I want to do
is give people a chance of like hey see
my work if you like each other around
there that's it just jut give me a fair
chance so I feel like I get that because
of these shows that I get to come on
like a shelf people are laughing
different now in the room like when you
guys get on stage you know when the
laughs turned to age it was just
something different yeah he's that's
kind of sexy fun boys man he just comes
real yes hey he's got a very relaxed
voice and when he comes in the jam and
the way sometimes like I'll Donald just
he'll just whisper a little bit I'll get
close but hey say say say say I'm smooth
jazz smooth jazz oh yeah uh-huh
say yeah 100 fat count returned if you
don't like it
hundreds count twice a hundred thread
count a hunch I ready I don't like
return if you don't like it hmm
no you're thinking I'm overthinking it
yeah sorry that was a bad read your
chance I did that's all right
oh well this is what acting is about um
another company I'm a I'm an absolute
fan of and customer ought to start using
a do or hims gotta straighten my hair
looks beautiful 40% of men oh and here's
the thing about for hems it's not just
for hair if you lose in your hair
word percent of men aged by it by the
age of 40 struggle with not being able
to get or maintain an erection canal
sometimes it does and that's what
happens sometimes you need to wake them
up but then see people go to gas station
and do all kinds of science and medicine
they can help you forget the solutions
back by science y'all realize these
fda-approved pharmaceutical products yes
II D erectile disfunction answer a few
questions your medical history a doctor
looks at it and boom when you get
approved it shows up at your door it's
super discreet all right so let's toast
to the biggest year yet and get your
wee-wee ready and your hair ready try
him today by starting out with free
online visit go to four hymns calm slash
fighter IDI that's fo r hims calm slash
fighter IDI for him calm slash fighter
ii d.c website for food full details and
safety information this this could cost
hundreds if you want in-person at dr.
lobster pharmacy but don't do that
remember that's for hems calm slash
fighter IDI the best supplements on
planet earth well know what honest
supplements do you take every morning
you know to only you know it's the only
thing that hits this sweet mouth yep I
take the creatine
I think I do that's why I'm so thick I
find it you know when I gives me energy
I swear to God I think there's a
difference I really do
they and every buddy I've heard every
expert says the one thing they all agree
on is create scenes commuting helps man
we didn't helps get some on it creatine
in that blood come take that favorite
service grow new trends I like earth
grow nutrients I like this total gut
health right now so much because I'm
carnivore
so yeah break down all that red meat
like a t-rex
Carillo joining oh they got it all man
if you're complaining maybe on the road
all the time maybe a comic whatever the
hell you're doing you just in your work
you can work out from your goddamn
living room with on at 6:00 bodyweight
workouts on-demand training go to AA
Netcom slash fighter for 10% off you are
in your shoe head to one of these guys
I'm not a shoe head I'm not a fox hey
boomer sneaker at the granite sneaker
head sorry those are interesting the
pink ones and he doesn't you don't wear
the same sneakers today right sneakers
range love club these are hard to get
daddy daddy that's why I think is so
interesting about your comedies because
you're a guy I was telling you in the
tech sector deadly can [ __ ] kill
someone but then you won't wear the same
shoes a day in a row so it's like you're
a deadly gay in the closet guy yes which
is like I'm like that too but not a
deadly we're a couple day Minges but I
write write but you're actually
admittees the gay ninja ninja yeah which
is great which is interesting that's so
relatable and cool
you notice when you're hanging on me I
said how many comics come and come up
new tux shoes I know just for that five
minutes you and I ran all shoes with all
shoes
oh yeah some guy said to me he goes so
you wouldn't you're with job and you
guys are wrestling do you let you let
him kind of just beat you up like that
and I went what do you mean well I mean
you're you're you're let them do that
stuff obviously you could you could if
you you've bought back a little bit oh
no no never never buy take to my show yo
yeah but think I'm stupid that human is
do you know they may understand dude you
know they do that guys lilius more well
people just don't people just don't know
I literally cuz you know Tom Segura is
doing his fan podcast in Spanish now yes
so my kids mom's family you know Puerto
Rican they speak Spanish they start
listening to podcasts
one of the [ __ ] one of her Tio's I
don't know which one it was Ramon
whatever one of their uncle's sort of
one of them one of the guys that knows
as we caught yeah yeah wasn't one of it
one of the JT toast comes up to me and
he says we're at a family party and he's
got a live rooster no what a family
court
it comes up to me and he goes he goes he
goes you noticed Tom Segura and I said
and I said yeah I shoulda you know I
know I'm you know I don't know well I
said but I know I'm a fan of his work
whatever I we've communicated a little
bit met him once and he goes out he goes
yeah I listen to his podcast it's pretty
good it's in Spanish I go yeah he goes
he goes he goes what is he like an
up-and-comer open my car and then I sent
him a article that the new seven million
dollar house he just bought I said yeah
there's your open my car yeah yeah
[ __ ] stupid Ramone Tim what do you
want dum-dum how dummy and open my car
open like what what is he Spanish does
that was his first language Spanish yeah
well he does his mama is yeah something
like yeah not but is it my Nicky Spanish
but not Mexican it's Spanish I don't
know if it's Cuban I feel what it is
Porto Ricans I'm not a teaspoon I figure
what it is hi buddy Spanish but yeah he
does a podcast on Spanish and now he's
doing a special in all Spanish smart he
signed to with Netflix for one rather
special one Spanish special amazing yeah
he's uh he's only been probably of nine
years he'll Peruvian who's got good
culture they make good uh potatoes so
I'm gonna do hiya Wasco yes sugar as a
beast man me real moneys ya mannan stir
so I know I don't know biro yeah what
can you do there's nothing you could
really do Brad then do me I like it you
got on it's your month
what were you say yeah you got like a
nice paint on your shirt came from
painting guys guy he fell into a short
coma why he's he overdosed on GHB and
fell into a short coma
oh how do you what top lesbian you're in
you reading Wikipedia like it's real
probably gonna put that maybe I doubt
that happen I don't do any drugs I did
edibles once not for me dude I literally
did okay with the great Sherrod smalls
another New York legend I also got a
piece on him oh my god you [ __ ] and
it's not circumcised bring him out he's
got girls rod Sherrod has apparently an
impossible piece huh hmm he and already
effort well it hasn't throught small
yeah I know I know of his piece big big
big piece yeah good man absolutely yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's um hey so yeah right
but yeah right what do you
right looking at see poking through you
think if that's Christian Finnegan but
that's Shiraz Derick yeah this is nice
white fat [ __ ] yeah and then um so I I
was with great OB from the Opie and
Anthony shell and sherrod had given Opie
edibles in a chocolate bar right and I
didn't I never taken Edel's before I'm
not a drug I don't know Opie just gives
me the chocolate bar I don't know you
supposed to take half of a half of the
square of the chocolate bar okay so oh
I'm and I love sweets I mean I got hot
coolant you know Michael's 250 others
have sweet tea so I love sweets you know
so I literally oh we're on the train
don't of the Islanders game New York
Islanders game and Opie just gives me
the chocolate bar and just starts
looking at his phone so I didn't know
you supposed take half of half of square
I ate the entire chocolate bar just to
the head Sherrod smalls we did get
chocolate oh my god okay
I forget that it even happened because
OB just forgot me was like not doing the
weed so hoping he just gave me the chalk
bar didn't even think about it I just
[ __ ] crush this thing right having a
good time all of a sudden right the
Islanders game first period buzzer goes
off man I thought somebody threw a spear
from the top of the jumbotron under my
right through the right side of my head
cutting off the left side of my body I
pop up a nasty I go I'm having a stroke
I'm having strong so I'm yelling at I'm
having a stroke right I forgot that I
was even on edibles I'm convinced I'm
having a [ __ ] show yeah
so I go up the stairs and I'm just
walking around I'm like I'm having a
stroke okay I'm having stroke he's like
you're not having struck I'm like dude
I'm having a [ __ ] stroke I'm at the
left side of my arm it doesn't work and
I'm like flinging my arm and it's not
working so then I'm like I'd have to
throw terrifying dude so I'm in a packed
Islanders game and this is New York City
I'm a big andhe's fan Opie's a big
Islanders fan so people know who we are
of course they know Opie and they're
like so they'll stop at COP they're like
oh that guy's always on the show so
they're talking to me and I'm trying to
have these dude the actual just as luck
would have it the Islanders broadcast
team in trevita dopey and brought me on
the interview oh yeah
I cursed on [ __ ] SN why would you say
I yelled [ __ ] the Rangers because
they're playing the rape so they're like
you know camera down
see yeah you know so I literally I had
gotten tickets I had gotten tickets from
the Islanders the ticket Kinect was mine
from the island just so they found out
that I yelled [ __ ] the Rangers lose the
tickets I leave I leave Barclays Center
like walk up to a police officer who's
in full SWAT riot gear because I mean
it's New York City
these guys have real jobs to do this
terrorist activity I woke up to him I
said officer I'm gonna be 100% honest
forthright with right now
Ivan jested drugs and he goes up he goes
and he goes what do you mean he goes up
I said I said I'm having a stroke he
goes and he goes okay
what kind of drugs did you ingest I said
I can't tell you the type of marijuana
strain that I've ingest it consumed an
illegal amount of drugs I was trying to
use all these professional words dude he
started laughing at me so hard I thought
he's gonna shoot his gun in the he goes
kid get the [ __ ] out of here movie and I
was like you know so he goes kid get the
[ __ ] out of here so I get in a cab it's
on 4th Avenue and 8th Street I get in a
cab I'm like take me to where I live 4th
Avenue and 93rd Street so the by the way
it was so I it was freezing was January
but I had my Jaclyn I was so [ __ ] hot
I asked his cab driver to open up all
the windows this guy open up all the
windows and he was like shivering and
freezing I was like guy I'm sorry I'm
having fun to stroke right now I'm on
drugs you got to keep these windows down
and he was like I'm so cold
I'm so cold I was like if you could show
me a value as passport I'll put the
windows up cabdriver said they're
staying down in room so
no realization I know dude I was high
literally dude it's 40 or 93 the cab
drivers stopped at a light I fourth the
Evan 163rd Street I look out I'm like
I'm home I open the door I open the door
and he's like I thought I was on 93rd
she put the six and the nine were you
know reversed in my head bro I'm [ __ ]
sweating it's like eight degrees out I
throw my jacket like a $400 North Face
jacket in a public garbage pan in New
York City Mac right in Sunset Park
Brooklyn I start sprinting home I don't
know what the [ __ ] is happening I didn't
live with my kids mom at the time I go
to my kids mom's house it's 10 o'clock
at night I ring the bell home do it I
ring the bell
she goes what are you doing here I was
like I'm having a stroke and she was
like Kris you're not having a stroke
I said I'm having stroke I have ingested
I've ingest it drugs so she goes oh my
god she goes alright come in so she goes
you have to take a shower she knew she
used drugs and she was a kid
it's like you have to take a shower
she's like I'll shower and I know I know
she goes take a shower love you dad yeah
so I take a shower I take a [ __ ] yeah I
[ __ ] start drinking this milk and
then I take a shower I take a shower
with my shoes and socks on so that means
I got completely butt-naked I put my
socks on my shoes back on I step in her
shower I haven't heard this story like a
black guy at this point exactly
yeah I gotta get the grip totally taking
a shower with my [ __ ] shoes and socks
on and then it's like I'm literally it's
getting bad and then out of nowhere just
bang I start hysterical laughing just
hysterical laughing having the [ __ ]
best time and then it was going back in
waves hysterical laughing terrified
hysterical laughing terrified I slept on
the floor in my at that time 2 year old
daughter's room all true I sleep on the
floor with her heart she's got a stuffed
animal piggy she [ __ ] loves its
animal
I at some point in the night I take
piggy off her bed sleeping on the floor
I wake up Piggy's mouth on my taint
literally and I was sleeping but naked
on my dark my two knurled daughter's bed
in front of me but [ __ ] to think about
what she has to wake up to yeah three
years old her father who does live in
the house anymore is naked with her
favorite stuffed animal even her dad's
ass my balls an [ __ ] and then
I woke up you know my kids mom like woke
me up and she saw what was happening
because she was the one who woke me up
she was like Chris you get out and then
and then like she sees the whole thing
and she's like this is why we can't be
together yeah we can't be why you can't
do it that's the worst do it edibles man
39 talk me off I called him in the
middle of nights I ate a brownie same
thing exactly thing I kept pacing the
Roger potent him and they stay for yeah
I thought I was gonna die and I and they
the clock was moving so slowly I was
like what is it was a minute an hour by
him one minute with a foul by and I
called Artie I go I called the poison
control center and I go I think I took
too much marijuana and he said where are
you he said how old do i seven thirty so
we're we're all ready and I go I go oh
and I hung up on a house phone back then
right and then I called Artie and I said
I feel like I'm gonna die goose you're
not gonna die feel jumping and he talked
me down for 45 minutes dude who what
seasoned drug addict do you call you
call your boy gonna come up thank God
for RT because what kept me when it
comes we called Joey Diaz sometimes the
edible [ __ ] I did I got so high in
Jamaica with my girlfriend I got there
and I tipped the guys you have a wine is
really good damn I'm divorced now are
you seriously really yeah dude
what are you doing tonight I mean you
want to get some [ __ ] edibles sooner
than I know
tell me you a [ __ ] Devoy oh no
tortellini tush
we'll be there no you're not my guy I'll
[ __ ] cancel Kimmel right now yes
friends I'm saying you're not my type
man why don't we go to Jamaica why do
you keep looking me up and down like
that I didn't know you were [ __ ] stop
making this [ __ ] weird hon don't go
in honda now it's telling start about to
make him head what the [ __ ] you want to
do you want to get a timeshare I don't
think so I didn't know you were single
I'm confused
Wow your teeth are straight do it that's
the only thing it's straight about me oh
that's when you divorce listen what can
you do you know she gets half what can
you do no she's the best yes she
deserves more than that she's does I
know I know I love that I [ __ ] follow
real touchy subjects touchy subject we
can edit this out whatever you want Pete
Davidson
oh is that touchy too touchy no Pete
Davis is not touchy no no no it's um
because do you remember when I was I was
defending Pete
whenever I have interaction with Pete
Davidson right he's always so nice
that's a good guy and we exchanged
numbers you take back a little back and
forth and then I'm sorry Nausicaa why do
people give the guys so much [ __ ] just
get [ __ ] all these hot chicks and
rise talented and all that stuff and
then a bunch of people DM me was a dude
ash boy Chris why he gets so much hate
but and that's I was like I did another
dude so I text Chris randomly cuz i
watch Pete special I do well [ __ ]
people hate you on this guy well the
thing is crazy I just got in trouble for
this yesterday careful no in trouble for
no no no because no Pete the thing is
first of all I haven't seen or spoken to
Pete in years give your history with
people being people understand hey no
seriously Pete Davidson like to me I
consider him like a friend like I don't
know I don't know I have no I'm not a
part Pete's life you got home should be
like used to be real close yeah very
close but I don't know to me that was
how many years ago yeah [ __ ] whatever
eight years ago some people on the
Internet
yeah the time that's the thing that's
all the way back at 2014 people are like
things a night to know what happened
yeah so yeah basically no it's just like
it was just one of those things where
it's like again I'm just telling
story cuz you ask but I [ __ ] love I I
whatever I would be Pete's friend I feel
like I am Pete's friend I just don't see
the guy anymore
usual both bids you don't have to get
into the story no no I'm not trying to
shame PD no we're not trying to shame
Pete yeah I don't I again I just don't
know him but I think the reason why
people were messaging you about that or
you know whatever is because he's
[ __ ] internet fans which Thanks
Thank You Pete when we he was 19 I was
like 27 and my and a girl that I was
dating was was like 23 and then we we
mean the girl broke up and then and then
was we fully broken up and then and then
and then Pete just and we were all
friends and then Pete you know after we
broke up was like started dating that
girl and so but I was Pete's friend and
then they had a good relationship
whatever I mean it's what you guys are
all friends I don't know forever but
absolutely girl so because I want to
show at that point called guy code so
all the guy code things like you broke
guy code Pete you broke up yeah but I
thought he was 19 when he was 19
number two it's not like anybody like
cheated on anybody was like we broke up
you all friends and he and the girl
broke up and then Pete dated her later
and then Pete apologized to me like six
months after everything
Pete was like hey I shouldn't have done
that I was wrong while he was still
dating her all good all good man so so
but I think but like I think the fan I
think that's why if you're asking me
that question that's why the fans
without because they don't know they
don't they don't have a reason they I
don't think anyone can come up with a
reason he's a good guy end of the day
well as far as I know as far as you know
great yeah so I don't know so I think I
think with Pete but yeah I wish I would
CP I just the thing is when these guys
get on SNL like an you know feed and
michael channel they're so busy that you
don't see him anymore you know you got
from a new set so writing all day every
day
you know so otherwise they get written
off the show or fired yeah so I know it
so I don't when they drop into the
Comedy Cellar we all say hello and hang
out but for the most part yeah I don't I
don't see him very funny I never seen ya
yeah I don't uh yeah I don't know we'll
see I mean [ __ ] think about how hard
it's got to be magic being that young
and getting pushed into the spotlight
that quick and why did it happen
form that couch I was he's super
talented but who discovered him cuz he
was how old when seventy twenty years
old but so I can even when he started
doing stand-up right yeah oh yeah no
when Pete yes young it was started
sixteen what perspective do you have at
16 he was good I he well he got a lot I
mean his dad died in 9/11 so he went
through some [ __ ] I'm so so he was like
one of those like he and went through
some pain already
so I think that's what it is with with
PETA yeah he was just good at it at a
young age but you know I guess at times
suffers from depression and stuff I to
be honest with you anything that the
public knows about Pete that's what I
know about P because I just don't you
know again I would I'm just I you know
like you just lose touch with people I
just don't sure I don't see or talk
about I think P probably is harder on
himself than anybody else needs to be
sure you know that's what what I gather
if I don't know anything about him but
it seems like a good guy
funny talented social media [ __ ] you
want to talk about a big [ __ ] dick
energy he started big together yeah he's
got a piece of kids got a pup up up up
up up he's I think he might be ten no
warts in clean chef and they're saying
it's circumcised and circumcised cuz he
from he's a white kid from Staten Island
so those kids yeah I don't think you can
leave the hospital s you without the
force you come out with the foreskin
yeah no good it's Catholic it scoffs
yeah yeah apparently he is just that big
dick like you've never seen it I give it
a twirl now he wouldn't pull he was
while he was that's another that's one
of the honesty thing that I do get upset
about most of Peters because he was 16
17 years old when we stopped really
being friends or like you know he was a
minor but I wish he was 18 because I
would have demanded to see his penis you
know I would have liked hey you got to
fight me to get out of this doorway
unless you put your dick now big dick
Energy's gone it's big dick spirit it's
big dick yeah told you how tall is he
tall she's tall tall tall drink of water
tall lanky thing 6-3 6-4 seeing guys
like that like like thinner guys like
that you get [ __ ] hit with an elbow
like that you're gonna get knocked
unconscious
they'll split open and I sure you know I
don't like to fight a skinny mini like
Rob Owen I calm Rob weird says six one
PDT is way taller the definite six one
yeah he's what
no ariana grande kate beckinsale real
nice lineup he does well what are like
well I mean what's he what's his
nationalities good I don't know he looks
almost like he's ambiguous yeah CED the
good old PDD yeah I miss him hopefully
you know hope he's doing well American
sounds like he's doing well
oh yeah I was gonna scare ya Netflix
special SNL uh Mia I hope he's doing
well I'm [ __ ] taking Spirit Airlines
to Vegas in an hour
no English Miss Jewish is he Jewish
there you go my father was Jewish
yeah mother's Irish to her my fries
Catholic yeah I wonder what that means
you know 9/11 what I guess Jews go to
heaven right there's no heaven in the
Old Testament okay did you know that oh
that's right when you die no heaven
loves the earth yeah you're you just
have you know Moses and Abraham they all
lived you know in the Bible two hundred
and fifty years and [ __ ] tons of
kids yeah I'm I'm a Catholic but I'm
kind of like more reformed now I got
Catholic tattoos on my body but you know
yeah yeah I'm counting my mother's very
very very Catholic she's a Catholic [ __ ]
you grew up going to church all going to
church big time and my my friends my
friend's dad I think was Tom Schiller
this Tom's loose flying around Tom
Schiller sure Lou told me he said he
said to his dad because I'm his mama
goes nut kornek Church and his father
said no I said uh you know I'm When I
was your age I had a moment where I
decided I wasn't gonna go to church my
father sat me down and said you going to
church and at that time he goes you're
going to church yeah and I was the
[ __ ] way it was yeah I went to camp
and in Wolfeboro New Hampshire as a kid
who never grew up in the United States
it was all Irish Italian where she's not
you you we went to church and when I
didn't go to church my buddy Tom's just
looked at me and went like this shook
his head like disappointed yeah dude I
was an altar boy like I was like a
Catholic [ __ ] warrior an altar boy
and then twelve years old I got clipped
by father Bill okay
when you and I got clipped my father
bill emotion toward me say don't say
clip be more respect I'm 12 you're 12
year old you know cells I'm an example
when I was 12 oh when I was 12 go ahead
oh sorry yes I'm a game clip just real
quick yeah couple of things happened in
the summer of what was that night summer
of love night I was molested doing yes I
was
so the yeah see I'm I've said this on
the last pockets but yeah the the
Mackenzie brothers held me down and the
older ones called me when I was taking
the mick ng boys what happens I'm
sitting down taking it [ __ ] I was to run
to the group I was 12 years all these
kids were 16 17 early 20s a problem so I
would hang out with the young kid they
would have me do you know like they're
running forties with mustaches yeah they
were like rouse me like you know I kind
of like because I was young they would
like you know make me do all these
things like I remember one time they
asked me they were like yo dude like
water Chinese food they're like get butt
naked they said and put on this Miami
Dolphins helmet and your mother's high
heels and I was like that okay that's a
weird I swear to God
so we opened the door so they said and
then answer the Chinese food goddess yo
to be funny answer the Chinese answer
the for the Chinese would like that with
the Miami Dolphins helmet on bought
naked your mother's high heels I was
like absolutely dude I want you guys to
like me so and so so true comic and I'm
making how this true crack in the mix so
literally we all go down with like dying
left this week right open the door see
obviously the Chinese guys [ __ ]
surprised then they push me out the door
and lock the door so now I'm butt naked
on the actual public Brooklyn Street
with China when the Chinese delivery guy
yep fought naked with my mom's high
heels which now flown off my shoes fell
off like the Jerky Boys with my [ __ ]
Miami Dolphin Town and then they made me
stay out there for about two hours oh
wow yeah not so anything I know it was
like a brisk March day so um so that
happened so I was like ah but these guys
love me and then and then I was sitting
on the toilet
one night one day taking a [ __ ] and one
of them jumped on my lap and then the
other one got up and just [ __ ] gave
me a nice pump nice skull-fuck pump two
pumps and I my head hit back it knocked
off at my mouth I swear to God knocked
off a tile
my mother's one of our ceramic tiles and
grab him [ __ ] knocked it
back off like literally at Iowa your
friends were gay yeah you you know that
story's a hard Center because that's so
[ __ ] specific yeah my head hit the
tile and appraised I was just taking a
shitty shove [ __ ] around literally
hard dick to open up my mouth and pop
one and we scan I was like and I was
like nah dude McAndrews a couple of
pitas working in tandem and then sand
that you know I've told that story once
it's somebody's like oh my god like
that's like you should report it to
police like that you were like sodomized
and I was like yeah but as the Mackenzie
brothers dick was coming out took a lick
on the tip like a cookie pop I what I
think I was being raped until I saw that
peel then I just took a little I took a
little lippy hippie yeah I just you know
what I mean yeah here's the thing they
had to have planned that slap let me get
my dick hard I'm gonna put in his mouth
there there they should be in jail
probably right but I don't [ __ ] care
because the thing is is this here's
because here's what happened because it
internally motivated me because they
were always making fun of me always
picking me last you know bouncing the
ball off my head I could steal my
mother's credit card and order
you know mattresses to her house like
doing crazy [ __ ] like that
they killed my dog ya know be honored
your fans know my friend they're still
my friends to this day I'm not even
drunk being silly like dog killer
pedophile like literally they already
used to order mattresses to go with them
as long as you're not a dog or a child
right they used to take shits in my sink
religiously shits in my hamper and
whatever but I was young I was like to
run to the group but internally
motivated me to like want to be like you
know better than them in school better
than him in sports and then I got all
these accolades doctor degree a
all-american basketball I think a lot of
the story in my mouth
and with all due respect fabricated
because you don't come forward till they
yeah I don't think doctor degree I don't
think
yeah I'm a doctor what my doctorate in
physical therapy and I have a division
three all-america basket players you
could google that I swear to God but
Google vez no Christian Stefano Duggal
Christa Stefano basketball all-american
dt isd is te fa n el Amerigo
I gotta get Brent and you gotta get
involved in this now di ste fno and then
is it d3 all-american d3 all-american it
was element all-american basketball
all-american basketball yeah let's see
let's see if it comes up and then and
then you can put boom Krista Stefano st.
Joseph's College Brooklyn inductee to
the Hall of Fame Krista Stefano yeah and
then and then and then ya plus plus
another Krista Stefano click images
let's see then you want to see some [ __ ]
in there right yeah CT colo it to the
right number 45 yeah I can there it is
American History X shape skinhead and
then I have a doctorate degree in
physical therapy that's all because I
was skull-fuck by the McKenzie doctor
physical therapy do Krista Stefano dr.
ho I received my doctorate in 2010 from
the New York Institute of Technology on
Long Island was like yeah dude there's
three now shoot I could [ __ ] fix your
wrist right now man that's great a guy
you give me a little bit excess can I
tell you what you're funny and I'll
[ __ ] fix your restaurant follow I
follow physical therapy Instagram post
and I do the exercises I'm pain free
dude listen
I mean look yeah doctor okay there it is
idea there dr. green physical you were
just [ __ ] around physical therapist
babe I'm telling you man so that's
all-american back out there I encourage
you to skull [ __ ] you I bought a white
point guard all-american basketball yeah
I was I and then I yeah I just um that
my whole life before there it is a
doctor with his sense of humor I Mohegan
Sun Wow
yeah so um but that's yeah that's all
because I took one off the uvula in on
96 Wow
yeah my right tom so got a [ __ ] you
know what uvula means I know what is
usually the anybody know what all that
stuff is now we're was your plan to get
a with was standing up Plan B because
because you were gonna get caused
agreeing do all this ginga-dono I got it
I got the degree and I was like so you
were like if that doesn't work gallium
fall back on this I started
simultaneously doing stand-up the third
year of my doctoral program
and then I and then I got to a point
where because I was on guy code and girl
code and those shows started to become
very popular you know the principal of
the school is like look you can't be
doing a show about hiding your boner the
guy code - hiding your boner and then
treating children with disabilities so I
left my physical therapy I left the job
and then started doing stand-up photo so
was it for you you were working with
children I was a PD I was a special
specialized pediatric physical therapist
Christ because they open now dude that's
[ __ ] yeah well that's what it is man
you don't like that work not as much
Intel [ __ ] door no no no physical
therapy oh I loved I loved being a
physical therapist it's very gratifying
to help like mentally and physically
handicapped kids but that's why I like
comedy - because it's gratifying I like
helping people yeah you know so and
that's it's weird because I tell those
stories and they're all are true my
friend you're so full people are like
people like dude you literally need to
go to therapy and all that I'm like I
don't know man I still love those guys
like I would help those guys with
whatever they need it they they they
[ __ ] with you a lot talk to me a lot but
I feel like if my brother's my big
brother [ __ ] if that didn't happen to me
because he was also a lot of good things
they did you know the skull [ __ ] is
having the stone so [ __ ] the match
system killing one of my mother's dogs
by giving it Clorox was um Wow
you know I guess these are all illegal
things but you have this Gentile it this
is pre 9/11 but what are those broader
bums dead as expected
one of whom time one of them works one
of them one of them works some [ __ ]
job in a bodega there you go and the
other ones like divorced and just a
piece of [ __ ] and wants to you know
always ask me if I if I find he can
manage my career there you go so in many
ways I feel like I've won yeah joke's on
you cause I said big triceps pushing
down the gay that's all from them so
yeah yeah yeah congratulations
yeah I mean listen I'm 35 years old
right now I mean I'd be shocked if I
don't kill myself before 40 but you know
I don't think you're going to yeah you
never know you're a sneaky accomplisher
I am a sneaky little I'm asleep
that's bets that being that good at
basketball could you play d1 basketball
I got so Jim Boeheim the coach of
Syracuse I was at
Eastern Invitational where they invite
the top 200 players at each position so
when I got I got invited for point guard
and shooting guard when I was my last
year of high school and he told me you
know what he was like you have a
Division one jump shot and in Division
three body so he said that's
unfortunately that's your truth
you got a d1 jump shot but it isn't a
Division three body just like me you're
just too short just like a prominent
casting director told me once he said I
don't think you're ever gonna really
work in Hollywood cuz you have leading
man face best friend body so it's just
so you couldn't you didn't have the Utah
how tall I'm six one so I think the
reason where my jump shot came from this
is another true thing my Stockton John
Stockton my father wallchuck John
Stockton is great but my father who was
you know in and out of jail there to
tell you guys about my father on the
show okay so my father he is great dad
and he really wanted me to play
basketball so he would take me down to
farmers all the park in Ridgewood Queens
every day during the summer and or as
much as you could when he wasn't in
prison and we would take a thousand jump
shot today and we would take a thousand
jump shot today so we take and he would
grab my rebounds and just bang jump
shots jump shots jump shots and then the
last hundred number one they had to be
all swishes so even if it winning there
wasn't a swish it didn't count 100
swishes I had to hit all hundred and
then he would have a broomstick that was
like seven feet tall because he wasn't
wanted to mimic a seven footer and then
on the broomstick for no reason he had
wrote in the word Leroy honest so he had
a broomstick named Leroy and I was like
dad why is it Leroy he was like because
black guys names are Leroy I'm like it's
not 1971 and and that there's many other
types of basketball players other than
black night so Leroy the forensics great
to see her and I would shoot jump shots
higher arcing jump shots over that and
then so when I came out this Eastern
invitation I could just you know I just
hit shots Division three there was JJ
Redick was the best shooter
there was a my friend had a clip of him
ESPN was on ESPN
it was they had the number one two and
Division one leader Division two leader
Division three leader in three-point
field goal percentage and JJ Redick was
number one dude three-point field goal
percentage it was like whatever 48
percent or something like that or fifty
percent and then some other kid was d2
and then I was on the list because I was
leading d3 at that
when I didn't leave for the country but
I was shooting 70% from frieza's in my
senior year because I was just literally
I was like you're not gonna [ __ ] skull
[ __ ] me I'm gonna hit these threes she's
so it was literal in your face man the
ball was such a big part of my life that
my friends who come and watch me do
comedy they're like I can't believe I
don't talk about basketball like that's
what that's what anybody ever knew me
and my neighbourhood from so strange you
have to fit in and where I was really
like a black and Latino neighborhood so
it's like if you're not if you're gonna
be the white kid you know able to play
ball so yeah so that's what I did and
then and then yeah now you know what are
you gonna do yeah I wanted to ask you a
question about that so you were you were
hidden from what was your dad why was he
in jail all time he was in jail because
um I think he was like organized he
wasn't in the Mafia but it was like
organized crime related stuff but I
think he you know racketeering
collecting money logic mafia mafia he
was like those guys like they still
sitting outside on the like the on the
chairs and your movies like not in the
cafe but he's sitting down be like whoa
whoa what are you here for he was
connected connected so he would get
scooped up and go to prison you know
every other year and then my mother
graduated from Columbia my mother has a
Ivy League graduate woman so she and
they met at a walkathon my dad was a
good-looking guy my no he wasn't my
dad's disgusting his nicknames Tony
balls he would write Tony Black if we
would like sign in it like the Olive
Garden something that would be Tony
balls maybe a llz Jenny would always
write that and then they met at a
walkathon and my mom was walking in the
walkathon as a participant
there was like it's um cancer research
thing and my father was doing community
service on the side of the walkathon so
my father was that's where they met and
then it's interesting because my mom
they had they had me very early they had
me on like the second date and my mother
was very religious woman and and then
her whole life was like my mom's whole
life was like you will not act like your
father you will not you will not you're
going to pronounce your R's you're not
going to go to jail you're not gonna get
in trouble you gonna go to school you're
not gonna make the same mistakes
you're gonna wet you marry a woman and
then have a family you're not gonna do
these make these mistakes and I never
made any mistakes all I did was pursue
my education pursue my
then pursue my dream and my MA check
check check
and then my mother was so happy and then
30 years old go to [ __ ] this barn
Brooklyn Coney Island Brooklyn called
place to Beach I see my pigs mom dancing
around second date pregnant I did
exactly what my mother and my dad drains
dude that literally those think it's
inane do my daughter
this is [ __ ] it gave me like the
chills so like two months ago my
daughter's preschool teacher who has
been teaching preschool for like thirty
years she goes listen I know all the
jokes with the kids I know the farts the
flick in the boogers I know they're
being silly because your daughter did
something that I've never seen before
she said we were all getting ready for
dismissal she said and she comes out and
she has on like five of the classmates
coats she has on everybody's coats and
we're laughing because she's trying to
hug and she's bouncing off them like
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
she's like we're laughing hysterical the
teacher was like I've never seen that it
was a good [ __ ] she was like you know
your dad's a comedian so I was like
that's funny they're very she was like
so I think you should put your daughter
in comedy she's just got an original
mind it was great with the coats and
Baba so a couple days go by I'm telling
my mother you know me my mom and my
daughter hanging out and I'm like mom
Delilah did something she put on
everybody's jackets and like the bit
whatever and my mother goes I'll be
right back comes out takes a picture she
had forgot four years old me when I was
four years old her exact age all the
jackets on we I mean like gave me the
chills because I've never talked about
that bit my dog my mother forgot I even
did that it was 30 years ago yeah my
daughter it's in it was in her head
already so it's my so when I was when I
was younger I Stu have a recurring
nightmare about my mother I was on a
flying trapeze right and I was trying to
get away from my mother and my mother
was a witch okay
and my mother was chasing me on the
trapeze and I would be swearing at her
and it would make her more and more
angry but I couldn't stop swearing at
her right and then I would fall and she
would jump and catch me in midair grab
her nails and start tickling me with her
[ __ ] nails in my ribs there's a
horrible shape so I would wake up and I
had that recurring nightmare when I told
my mother that my mother went white she
used to have the exact same holy [ __ ]
sack same dude well two things number
one I'll tickle you anytime you want
that wasn't the point but you I also
have a nightmares one it's being raped
by priests
so Brenda doesn't care yeah well I um
dude I'll [ __ ] that's everybody's like
an amazing though that's crazy that's
amazing so cool man yeah well what can
you do you know and and yeah now I'm
here and I'm proud you know well do I
have a full-size basketball course if
you want to come over and get I'd love
to up come on over I'd love the way I
shot a ball I haven't shot a ball in
quite some time
but some memory I'm down I'm down it
yeah whatever you want to do you want to
shoot a little jump shots whatever you
want to do we should do teams we should
do team says I just want to make sure
Ari Shaffir is the coach I like what he
has to say okay so you guys know about
Tech Talk by now yeah hell yeah I feel
like we're too old for I just I don't
know I just went on it I just upload old
videos but okay so there's a new
challenge going around based off of a
2013 study that says that there are
taste receptors on your testicles and
now people on tik-tok are taking it upon
themselves to dip their balls into soy
sauce to see if they can taste them I
just thing is tain't your balls may have
taste receptors it doesn't have taste
buds so you can't taste the soy sauce
it's just a bunch of kids but your balls
are tasting the soy sauce technically
you can't actually taste it but
technically your ball the balls are
receiving the soy sauce yes I like that
yeah I wanted to told you that you can't
taste things through your balls but all
right yeah I totally I don't need to
drop them in soy yeah yeah eight you're
calm or anything like that never that
bad I'm very Spanish about that yeah
make sure you lose it there's a thing
called the snowball with a girl you come
the girl's mouth and she puts it in your
mouth oh that's gonna be the worst thing
I can't
I'm very doctor have you ever tasted
come yeah my own come I've tasted men's
come but not but not
no no no no no no no there's protein in
that I told you player base yeah last
try was Kido what do you want me to eat
oh so so it's mad yeah YMCA exactly with
a blindfold no I have to sorry
um you know what's wild thing about come
is um there's so when my kid's mom was
pregnant she was she was well we were
nine months she was passed for due date
and doula went to a duel I'm a nice
Jewish doctors we had so the doula they
know everything they're all they don't
even use the medicine a like we know how
to get I could get this baby out I could
just push it out of your belly button
yeah the gates vent or I could just pop
it out that's and so they know all the
tricks no medicine that's what we want
turn and she was great this doula so
we're to three days passed a due date
and they're asking me all this question
has all these questions and then they
say the doula says all Jewish woman she
goes um she goes here's what you need to
do if you wanna have this baby here's
what you need to do she goes there's
properties in semen in men's semen when
ingested when swallowed has released as
a chemical call to relax and that's the
name of the chemical relax and which
will open up yeah well it'll cause your
water to break and it'll it'll start to
open up your pelvic muscles and the baby
will start to come and so she was like
so you're telling me I need to give him
a [ __ ] and swallow it that's what
you're saying and then and then
literally know it's a woman and then say
it's a girl and then and then and then
shoot my kids mom says to the Deutsch
like did you pay her to [ __ ] say that
and I was like no I was like I'm just as
shocked as you are and she's like well
it's not gonna happen I'm not I'm nine
months pregnant I don't want to do it so
I was like yeah I mean [ __ ] whatever
what everyone do babe I'm here then like
whatever a couple hours gone by I'm
sitting there and we're just like
waiting she's pacing back and forth
we're watching TV and she goes pull your
dick out right now she goes just pull it
out and put it on my mouth right now and
I was like we don't have to whatever she
goes put into my mouth and then she
[ __ ] milked me with her mouth she
literally was like are you gonna [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it's like and then literally
that for some reason made me [ __ ] cuz she
had like that yeah yeah because the way
she screamed in here grasping it sounded
a little bit like a father Bill I'm in
Seoul
so I sprayed it then literally 15
minutes
Coosh water broke [ __ ] baby came out
eight hours later she was like literally
like crowning like literally crap
pushing the baby out my father walks
into the hood it's just my mom and her
mom and me thanks to here come my father
[ __ ] walks in to the delivery room as
like literally my baby's head is coming
out is I well don't have a baby then I'm
like and then she's like get out of here
and then my dad's like goes ah he goes
we're gonna have a baby I'll be outside
it goes yo Christie by the way Yankees
got [ __ ] rocked last night it's about
he got [ __ ] rocked last night and
then my dad this is what a compulsive
gambler my dad is he bet with my uncle
five hundred dollars on my child's
gender cuz we didn't have a gender
reveal
he'd bet $500 and he put 500 is gonna be
a boy any any flaw so you don't have to
[ __ ] pay my uncle Jesus that's what
it did Jenna that's why I love my death
sounds gray my dad are very close
because he's get him on the podcast he
would love to come on the podcast he
always had like the right intentions but
like the wrong moves like divorced from
my mom you know very early jail jail
yeah well like very much like Chris like
you know like I'm gonna show you how to
do things like my mother started dating
this guy dude it was the work
imagine being 15 years old now at you
think about we're 15 old kids my mom
started dating one of my best friend's
father's do you understand how brutal is
you're feelin and us though yeah you're
[ __ ] drinking beers in your garage
you're acting like kids and then there'd
be a lull in the conversation sometimes
like what do you think Gary's dad's
doing I don't know banging Chris's bars
just like fighting hey I can't [ __ ] it
up again come on mom my mom's [ __ ] my
dad's brutal dude so anyway this guy
cheats on my mother starts dating the
woman who lives directly across the
street real playboy yeah real [ __ ]
disgusting Pig of a guy and that broke
my mother's heart right I'm 15 years old
and I'll never forget I was having this
[ __ ] bad psoriasis flare-up
I would just flare up right probably
causing psychological trauma dude I'm
telling me now that you're divorced just
explore you know dude yeah just explore
it man you love to rub muscle man tries
you've never gotten roadhead like a guy
who's unless I don't yeah so I so I so
I'm like I'm sitting there I'm 15 years
old my mother's looking out the window
at the cross the street because the guy
who was just dating a week go he's
cheating on her dumped her this woman
lives across street and my father was
coming to pick me up to take me to
baseball practice and and he goes um he
sees my mother crying I said what the
[ __ ] is what's going on with her because
he's still like loves my mom he's and
then I go and I'm like oh I remember
that guy remember that guy she was
dating a [ __ ] Gary's dad well he
dumped her and he's dating a woman who
lives across the street and he's like
you gonna do something about that I was
like I'm 15 years old I have psoriasis
possibly do like [ __ ] been
traumatized my whole life I'm just went
am I gonna H and he goes um because I'll
be right back this true story I saw this
with my own eyes he goes I'll be right
back
so he goes downstairs and he goes don't
come outside I'm gonna get us bagels but
don't come outside and I was like okay
well I'm coming outside cuz like you
know so literally I [ __ ] creep down
the stairs like I have my mother's high
heels on you know like I'm just creeping
down just like so I look out the window
I see my dad ring the bell of the thing
across the street and he must said he
must been out he's a guy he goes uh
[ __ ] it's John around the woman who's
Gina answers door was her home he comes
out literally as he gets to the door I
see my dad grab him in one move grab him
and throw him down the stairs she just
said my dad's fat he'd like you it seems
like I'll [ __ ] rock this guy but he's
just got that psychotic yeah get some
[ __ ] throws it down the stairs
wattles down the stairs and starts
punching this guy in the face I ran
outside I hear my mother screaming Tony
Tony you're gonna kill him
my dad comes walking across the street
with blood all over like kind of like on
his shirt and on his hands and a little
bit on his face on my bladder
oh dude little he's walked across street
like Ray Liotta and Goodfellas
I felt like [ __ ] Carradine give a
[ __ ] just sitting I was like oh my god
I'm the gun I love that scene dude
that's literally what it looked like she
means and then he goes that was your job
that was your [ __ ] job and I'm like
what are you talking about jeez oh
that's right yes I was raped by priests
I'm like I can't emotionally do this and
then like it was always the same thing
three hours later we're driving over the
Verrazano Bridge on Staten Island and
he's like and he's like you know I
shouldn't have done that right you know
that was the wrong thing I shouldn't
have done that I'm like you know I know
Mom knows the police know we all know
she's like well all I was trying to tell
you was and I should have just used
words I was trying to tell you what
instead of sitting in your room playing
video games pitching your [ __ ] rash
go come for your mother when she's out
there crying I should use my words but
instead I use my dude yeah he used to do
[ __ ] wild [ __ ] all what I was at Doc
Goodin's no-hitter doc gooden so I know
hitter May 1996 I'll never forget
because it was doctor there's no hitter
and in just a few short months later if
my life is gonna change by the
skull-fuck and the prestress yeah
because that was also 96 but the summer
so so I'm sitting at the game we're in
the upper upper upper deck which I'm
fine with those seats but sure my dad's
like you know Dwight Gooden its seventh
inning no hits my dad's like this guy's
pitching in no no I Kevin kept saying my
did whites pitching in no no he kept
saying dry guys pitch in [ __ ] no no
and then so and then so he's like we
gotta get better seats and I was again
but it's fine you know oh and by the way
that day what do I couldn't snow hey
there was a Monday I had a science
project due the next morning the next
day and my mother had said my told my
father specifically leave after the
fourth inning he needs to be home we
have to gonna wake him up at 7 a.m. he
needs to finish this science project the
fourth inning Tony I'm serious now keep
mine it's 1996 no cell phones my
mother's I get my dad's again at a
fourth inning I got it don't worry baby
call my mom babe still like they've been
divorced 30 years but he still calls her
babe she's like this is offensive so so
he's like no problem babe I'll have him
back I'll see you know gonna cook dinner
she's like we've been divorced for 20
years you know he just doesn't get it
he still thinks her happily married I'm
like you live in a bath
so he goes so my dad this is it so we're
at the Yankee game now it's the seventh
inning it's [ __ ] way past the fourth
inning it's I see the time like dad mom
said to go home because listen Dwight to
pitch in and no no
so she'll understand no no yeah yeah
sure she'll understand she doesn't know
what baseball even is she's gonna know
what a no-no is so my mom so my dad goes
all right listen he goes it's coming up
on the eighth inning he goes we got to
get you behind home plate I gotta get
you behind home plate I said I hit but
Dad I don't care goes now he's pitching
a no no we're gonna go because you gotta
listen to me do everything I tell you to
do this is all [ __ ] like in slow
motion I remember this day in my life so
we get down to the security guard behind
home plate and my dad sees two or three
open seats right behind home plate right
in the old Yankee Stadium and he says to
the security guard he's like and he goes
listening cuz uh it goes you know it's
Dwight's pitch in and no no he goes me
my kid I mean first time I've ever taken
the Yankee Stadium that was like my 12th
game that season he's like the first
time I've ever taken on his [ __ ]
Yankee teams a big mom for my kid
Dwight's pitching no no there's two
seats come on let me just any you know
taking out cash my dad takes out cash
what do I need you know grease and
people and the guy goes no he's not he
can't sit down there I'm sorry gonna
have to watch him here no man that takes
your breath II goes he goes alright he
goes up but my son's got special needs I
looked up at him and I was like what
like special needs and then I was just
sitting on with my mouth open like kind
of like with a half smile and then a
security guard gives me a noogie let's
have a good time kid gave me a complex
because I'm like I know I have like a
weird mushroom haircut Supercuts but I
don't think I look like I [ __ ] have a
special needs but I swear to god this is
where the story gets unbelievable but I
swear to god this is [ __ ] true the
row in front of where me and my dad are
saying now it's the ninth inning
Dwight's
two outs away from the no-hitter which
eventually yeah big deal he see I see I
noticed it's [ __ ] I'm 12 years old
height of the WWF big wrestling fan mr.
perfect who is that one row in front of
us mr. [ __ ] perfect the wrestler
every kid's favorite wrestler at that
time I'm like that that's mr. perfect
and he goes who's that
I go I go he's a wrestler and he goes
yeah I call I was [ __ ] great and he
goes and he just trusts Delanie he drops
the mystery goes yo perfect perfect he
goes give my son an autograph what about
getting my kid an autographed whites but
you did no no and then mr. perfect I
swear God turns around he goes no I
swear God goes no like he was just and
he is drinking and you know whatever my
dad does my son's got special needs by
mr. perfect and then we get back and it
was the same story of my father as it
[ __ ] always is we're a block away for
my mother's house two o'clock in the
[ __ ] morning home by 8:00 it's one
o'clock in the morning my dad goes don't
tell your mother what happened just
don't tell your mother what happened
tell there was a train delay a [ __ ]
trailer so literally I love your father
do we read a great [ __ ] dad yeah we
ring with it great thing right that and
then my dad is so funny cuz it's 2:00
a.m. and my dad used to sleep in the
basement cuz he had to go all the way
back to Staten Island and then was 2
o'clock in the morning and my dad starts
walking in to go to the basement and my
mother goes Tony get the [ __ ] out of my
to take the ferry and three trains all
the way back to its how special being
special and then and then yeah and then
I failed I didn't you know I got a D on
that science project cuz I just cleaned
it worth it worth it what's the plan the
kid I agree with you yeah that might
been one of my favorite stories and you
didn't think I'm kidding but I did it
makes me kind of think about how to
parent my son yeah I got to start doing
these massive two in the morning
yeah whatever like yeah dude I gotta
take me to a game I've never taken my
kid to a [ __ ] game ah dude my dad
that would literally know you please for
us for that was my dad's teaching places
for that anything like and it was always
rewards if I could get a good grade or
if I would you know clean my room or tie
up or my dad would be like the incentive
for you thank you the next game I'll
take any Yankees game I'm thinking uh of
New York Giants game so that and that
was all the moments with my father were
at stadiums great memories great moments
right mom's he's your dad halsy now my
dad's seven
the five years old now he's on dialysis
he's on dialysis yeah but how's he doing
otherwise he's doing no he's doing good
actually and it's comfortable circles we
used to sit in the upper deck at Knicks
games i remember i remember [ __ ] what
I'm an innocent little kid of you know
ten maybe even younger nine at Madison
Square Garden this was actually my first
Knicks game that my dad took me to so
maybe I was younger maybe I was eight
and I Patrick Ewing [ __ ] tomahawk
dunked on somebody against the Orlando
Magic Shaquille O'Neal I believe maybe
was even a rookie don't on Shaquille
O'Neal and I got up and I went oh my god
he just slammed that like a monkey and
then what oh like that I my dad was like
but I just didn't know you thought he
look like a one off the roof yeah my dad
was like and then he explained to me
like why I can't what that means and I
was like aw [ __ ] so it was like I
remember that moment and then it comes
full circle because like three months
ago I got courtside seats from you know
having my own New York Knicks
connections from career stuff and we got
to sit courtside yeah we got this you
and your dad yeah seems like - I think
if it's funny because when you sit
courtside when you get these certain
connections whatever they put you up on
the jumbotron right so there's just
[ __ ] horrible timing you know I don't
[ __ ] whatever I you know I bet on a
couple of shows but I'm not Jumbotron
material I mean even I know that I'm
like I don't want to do this so it's me
my dad and Phil Collins right my dad
said next full comps I'll never forget
my dad cynics Phil Collins and Phil
Collins had candy chocolate candy and my
dad's just eaten he was putting his hand
and he filled Colin's candy bag without
his permission and Phil Collins could do
nothing he liked he liked Phil like Phil
cons like my dad they were laughing the
whole time he was Tom Chris yeah he was
telling crazy [ __ ] stories he was
calling him Phillip he was like its
Phillies like you look like a fill up it
was just saying [ __ ] like that eaten
Phil Collins candy and then literally
they put Phil Collins up on the
jumbotron and they play his song
dududududududu standing ovation Wow Phil
[ __ ] Collins bag like ah dududu -
literally
fades out goes crazy they start playing
a clip of my standup I'm like nah
I literally hurts something awful close
I literally literally hear somebody from
like ten rows back who the [ __ ] is that
really goes up like I have video of it
on my Instagram deep in my Instagram
they put me up on the jumbotron you know
comedian Chris de Stefano you can hear a
pin drop you just see my father's hand
come and start rubbing in my back as I'm
getting a full zero from 15,000 people
in Madison Square Garden my dad's just
rubbing them back in here I'm gone it's
almost over I'm going deep in your
Instagram yeah it's up there it's like
one of those things is a full [ __ ] is
here you seem like they make you follow
[ __ ] Phil that's why I said listen
I'm appreciative of it's a nice moment
to be on a Knicks fan to be on MSG
Jumbotron once it's like a [ __ ] you
and everything that's gonna happen so
it's great not saying I deserve it but
it was great but I was like could I have
at least one before Phil I mean just
play that drum part he's like you know
[ __ ] yeah and then literally a full
zero just rubbing my back yeah Tracy
Morgan was there too Tracy Morgan's like
they did you call son yeah [ __ ] that's
so pseudo no idea from Thalia yeah you
might doing that [ __ ] I have the
stupidest memory of that when we were
playing in the air tonight and me and we
were all pretending that we're gonna do
we're gonna Sasson eight somebody out i
don't you were in college and I'm like
well by the way way too old for this I'm
[ __ ] giving him the gun and say and
we're gonna as were driving out the
window and my friend is so stupid I
don't know why it's funny but he just it
has the gun easy cuz he's lying there
like that as we drive by well
after this now that's it let's sit down
outside were story of all time Wow shine
moment yeah he died and that's myself in
shrine that's Mike Matt's my terrible
self a story and your [ __ ] what a great
story
you're a monster dude are you on the
road in Christ yeah I'm sure I thought
you wouldn't be able to join me when I'm
in New York May was 7th made you get on
in every picture
dude what it is you look I don't know
who that guy is that's me that's me with
a size 38 waist now massage 36 waist
state state hey Charlie good luck chunky
monkey well yeah so I'll be armed so
March 19th I have a history my hit
podcast history hyenas please go check
that out with the great ganas Papas we
have live shows at the Gramercy theaters
first show sold out second shows
available March 19th and April 29th at
the wall street theater in Norwalk for
the history i mean--is and then me just
me doing stand-up we got our Vancouver
new club yeah Rick brought its house of
comedy of Vancouver opened a new club
opening good guy I got laughs Boston I
just put Raleigh North Carolina up April
9 to 11 and then Philadelphia a Philly
punch line and then just added October
9th and 10th we got the Aladdin Theatre
in Portland and April on October 9th and
then October 10th the Neptune Theatre in
Seattle Washington I'll be bringing Don
de Pedra with me aka handsome Yanis so
go get those tickets d comedy calm Chris
D comedy calm do the best and we thank
you guys for having me Oh next week I'm
in Atlanta bucket theater that's Friday
the 13th and then Saturday March 14th
I'm in New Orleans
one night one show only each city then
following weekend March 19th through the
21st B Day weekend new guy let's get
weird to get some plans for Ryan's
divorce I'm divorced mm-hmm let's do man
I don't get a hotel yeah we could do it
19 Austin we're in Austin I'm now
stencil there that's very legal it's
actually yeah yeah it's weird
uh yeah March 19th through 21st Austin
cap city and then I close out the month
Toronto Detroit Minneapolis now I'm off
to Europe tik-tok um fatigue it's B
where am I
Kansas City the 3rd and the 4th of April
at the improv can't wait and then
Columbus Addie's back on the road
daddy's back on road I got a lot of
Columbus Ohio rally the April 18th Bay
Pro at the funny bone charlotte comedy
zone 23rd 24th 25th I don't like your
energy and then Denver I don't like your
energy from not buying to ticket
come on energy dude please all right
there you go
curse you the best you fighting the Tom
Chris thank you for joining us thanks
Bubba's [ __ ] grace the punk kid we're
out